Hey this is Presh Talwalkar.
There's a math problem that's gone viral
on Instagram with over 6 million views.
I'll read the question out for you.
There's a negative sign.
Then 9 squared plus 81.
What's the correct answer?
Tens of thousands of people are arguing
whether the correct answer is 162.
Or the correct answer is 0.
What do you think?
In this video,
I'm going to explain the correct answer
according to the modern interpretation
of the order of operations.
Under that interpretation,
the correct answer is zero.
I'm going to explain why.
We can remember the order of operations
by the acronyms PEMDAS or BODMAS.
This refers to parentheses/brackets,
exponents/orders,
multiplication and division,
and addition and subtraction.
If you have two operators of the same
precedence, evaluate from left to right.
In this expression,
we first evaluate the exponent.
So we have 9 squared, which is equal to
9 times 9, which equals 81.
We then have the opposite of 81 plus 81.
So we have an addition
and that's equal to 0.
And that's the correct answer.
Just for further illustration,
you could type this expression into Google
and it will show you
that the opposite of 9 squared
plus 81 is equal to 0.
And Google will even parse [it] out,
so you see a parentheses around 9 squared
so it's evaluated first.
And then you take the opposite
of 9 squared.
So the opposite of 9 squared
plus 81 is equal to 0.
But if you don't trust Google,
you could even type this into Wolfram
Alpha, which will show you
the opposite of 9 squared plus
81 is equal to 0.
Zero is the correct answer.
Zip, zilch, nada, शून्य (sunya),
squadoosh!
Now, if you didn't get this,
there is widespread misunderstanding
about this concept.
Several years
ago, a study of prospective elementary
teachers showed that they incorrectly
applied the order of operations
to compute the opposite of 3 squared.
So it's not just students
who get this wrong,
but even sometimes teachers
don't evaluate this correctly.
To further illustrate the point,
here's a clip from a textbook
that shows that the opposite of 3 squared
is evaluated as the opposite of 3 times
3, which equals -9.
This is definitely the way
that it's understood in mathematics.
So why does this matter?
Let's say you have a function f(x)
is equal to the opposite of x squared.
If you were to graph this,
it would be a parabola pointing downward.
Now f of nine would be equal
to the opposite
of nine squared, which is equal to -81.
It is not equal to positive 81.
So you have the point nine come in -81.
The concept even applies in higher
mathematics.
Here's
an equation for the standard normal curve.
So you would take the opposite
of z squared here.
And the standard normal curve
will look something like this.
So the opposite of 9 squared
plus 81 is equal to 0.
And I hope that we can end this widespread
misunderstanding.
Thanks for making us
one of the best communities on YouTube.
See you next episode of Mind
Your Decisions where we solve the world's
problems, one video at a time.